Alexander has been a topsy-turvy game
this one and previous game as well but
you got it done very complicated middle
game Yasser was saying that this is what
chess should look like tell us about a
bit about your story and I think the
opening went well for me and then I'm
like totally misplayed the middle game
and I believe at some point to got
better and according to him he was uh
close to winning and really he was at
what point when he played at five
yeah he said that instead of F5 taken on
D4 and just
taking on D4 and just sacrificing the
piece on A4 that's what he spent his
time on close to winning is a maybe yeah
maybe it's an exaggeration it's like uh
yeah but
definitely didn't look very convincing
for me okay but F5 I believe it was just
a blunder
um
I don't know after Rook C2 I think black
is already close to losing D5
immediately probably better but
shouldn't change that much yeah it's uh
I believe I should be better now yeah so
again if uh even if Joe doesn't do
anything instead of playing F5 just
standing there I don't think I can do
anything
on
no I don't know about my conversion here
I was chosen which piece to live for him
bishop or a knight and uh maybe uh made
a wrong choice I think the conversion
was clean enough yeah yeah stabilize the
position don't get checkmated then
that's right so
so
uh yeah but uh another game ended up
unfavorably for me uh
big hope Gregory and just uh
I couldn't couldn't do anything against
Malik Malik just was uh much better out
of the opening again and plain
incredibly confident right now and so my
only chances to win tomorrow and maybe
set up the but I have to say you're
playing against Malik in the last in the
last round yeah so if I'm down a point
it's gonna be a really a really fun game
but for that I need to win tomorrow
everything to play for absolutely in the
last couple of rounds Alex
congratulations for uh an important
Victory guys thank you congratulations